if you argue with a teenage girl
she will make you question your life
choices
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what teenage girls don't
give a [ __ ] about your feelings
hold on one second you guys you guys you
guys okay
you good man you good i've never heard
someone discuss a dessert so [ __ ]
loudly before in my entire life
yeah dude we each get a bite we no you
get a bite and then i get a bite we each
get a bite
take it easy there big fella all right
you were [ __ ] you were getting heated
you're getting sweaty on the top of your
head
this is my [ __ ] bite right here i
want the end bite we got it dude
yeah i didn't know there was such heated
dessert rules over here all right let's
just
if you could just keep your dessert talk
to just a little quieter that would be
great i appreciate it very much
you were [ __ ] listen nobody get in
the way of this dude's dessert you know
what i'm saying
there's some serious dessert rules going
over here
yeah it know this it was a serious
conversation i'm glad i broke it up you
almost took your glasses off you were
like i get the first [ __ ] bite
i ordered this [ __ ] i get the
first bite
yeah just just in case you didn't know
you were six inches from the stage
did you somehow think nobody would hear
you screaming about your [ __ ] cake
you think you're in the cones of silence
[ __ ] you're out in public bro
these people heard you over here they're
like let me eat the keg for [ __ ] sake
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah sam yeah that cake better be good
i'll tell you what
oh the edible is creeping up yeah it is
a little bit
[Applause]
i wasn't expecting no don't don't not
eat on my account man look at him now
you see him now he's eating like he's
super polite he's like
you got more cake oh you got more cake
coming yeah
oh that one's not yours that's a problem
and they put it in front of you and
you're like that's not my [ __ ] cake
yeah all right
i get it now and so you don't want to
eat that cake
why don't you move it then from the
front of your [ __ ] face oh yeah okay
[Laughter]
i mean you could have fooled me it
wasn't your cake it was eight inches
from your [ __ ] mouth the whole time
we were talking
yeah you could have just pushed it away
well you didn't want to touch it is that
the whole thing this isn't my cake this
is my [ __ ] cake
why did she put this cake in front of me
this wasn't my cake is that what it was
that's what it was like what cake are
you getting i'm just curious i wanted
the chocolate souffle
chocolate souffle again is it coming out
oh yeah
i can't wait for that cake to come out
here
what's your name man mark dude i've
enjoyed this conversation more than you
could possibly ever imagine
for here on out people are going to be
like were you at that cake show in
naples
are you mark's wife no okay
are you here with mark okay yeah
has he exhibited this type of aggressive
behavior
around cake before i don't know if it's
an issue
mark puts on that cake heat boy
all right listen by the way i'm buying
that cake for you by the way whatever
that is
whatever that souffle is well i'm gonna
buy that when i mean i'm gonna buy it
you guys pick up the tab for that i
appreciate that
[Applause]
so i see you're texting you're going to
miss all the [ __ ] cake talk there you
go
put your [ __ ] phone down put your
[ __ ] phone down put your phone down
put your phone down put your phone down
oh [ __ ] unless you're k
unless you're texting somebody this
[ __ ] cake thing is amazing i don't
[Music]
wanna
[Music]
you